Massachusetts it's ready to send its
first black Democrat to Congress after
another high-profile election upset
Boston City Council Anna Presley is her
name she won the Democratic nomination
in the state's seventh congressional
district primary last night she defeated
congressman Michael Capuano who was a
20-year incumbent at O'Keefe is on
Capitol Hill with the latest shake-up
for the establishment Democrats at good
morning this is big news there in
Massachusetts big news in Boston Gala
surprised virtually everyone including
the candidate herself video taken by one
of her staffers showed a reaction to the
news last night many are drawing
comparisons between Presley's win and
that of New York Democrat Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez who back in June defeated
another longtime Democratic congressman
but while Ocasio Cortez ran to the left
of her opponent Presley and Congressman
Mike Capuano actually didn't have too
many differences he's been a reliable
liberal over the course of his 20 years
in Congress but his Presley put it
recently it's not just good enough to
have Democrats back in power
it matters who those Democrats are
Presley is now one of a handful of
mostly female minority liberals who are
winning races across the country
Connecticut for example has probably
going to elect its first black female
congresswoman to Congress in November
down in Georgia Stacey Abrams is running
for governor
Andrew Gilliam of course won a primary
last week in Florida while Presley is
running unopposed however people like
Abrams and Gilliam may struggle to
convince general election voters this
November to support Norah a black woman
now representing a seat held by Joe
Kennedy and JFK jr. ed thanks so much